event this year uh timothy dolan is my
name i
happen to be the archbishop the cardinal
archbishop of new york and
i'm talking to you from what has been
the home of the archbishops of new york
for the past 170 years
given this difficult moment we're living
through with the pandemic
many of you probably are in your homes
as well
regrettably we aren't able to gather as
we normally do
for our formal dinner to help raise
funds for the most vulnerable members of
our beloved community
namely our children and their families
but we do have a wonderful evening
planned for you
now since we don't have a deus this year
to introduce
what do you say we begin the evening
with something special
let's go next door to st patrick's
cathedral america's parish church
where
[Music]
[Music]
fight
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
old
[Music]
[Music]
right
welcome again everybody to the annual al
smith dinner here in new york city
and thank you thank you for your company
your interest and your support but first
things first
let us pray in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy spirit
amen we stand before you
dear heavenly father as one nation under
god
that's a hope hardly a boast we profess
in god we trust admitting that at times
we don't as we instead place absolute
confidence in passing features of this
life
rather than in you alone and yet never
do we betray the faith of our fathers
as we turn to you constantly in prayer
asking your blessing upon our country
our two presidential candidates here
this evening
upon those who lead defend guard heal
and protect us
and upon the alfred e smith memorial
foundation
an instrument indeed of your mercy and
compassion
especially to women and children in need
and your blessing upon this evening of
unity joy patriotism and recommitment
to the foundation which depends upon the
generous benefactors of this
annual event those
ailing from the pandemic are civil
unrest or hurricanes or raging fires
and those who serve heal and protect are
high in our prayers as well
we unite those prayers with our jewish
neighbors during their holy days
as we pray through christ our lord amen
in the name of the father and of the son
and of the holy spirit
amen well for those of you just joining
us welcome welcome to the 75th annual
alfred e smith memorial foundation
dinner
what's the background here well no one
here this evening is old enough to
remember the 1928 presidential election
except maybe former vice president joe
biden in that year the immensely popular
four-term governor of new york al smith
became the first catholic nominee for
the high office of president
sadly the campaign was sullied by
anti-catholic anti-irish anti-immigrant
bigotry
and al smith lost big time yet never did
he lose his hope his dreams or his
compassion for those he
called the little ones neither has this
dinner in his honor since 1946
even during this tough year with all of
us united against coven 19
we still come together true not the jan
historic ballroom of the waldorf astoria
since it's closed but virtually honored
nevertheless to host remotely our two
candidates
president donald trump and former vice
president joseph biden
both of whom will address us plus our
splendid board and legion of benefactors
who have come through again this year
when the needs are so towering the
alfred e smith foundation a terror a
charitable
tax-exempt president trump knows what
that means
it's a vehicle of a hand up for the most
needy
of all faiths or no faith at all
but during this pandemic i've kind of
become accustomed to speaking to a big
room with a lot of empty seats and a
camera
namely st patrick's cathedral i
sometimes think that in this year of our
lord 2020 it's no longer
and with your spirit it's and with you
in spirit
over the past months our our priests
have had to get creative on sunday
mornings
via zoom passing the collection plate
via
venmo muting that one person who might
recite
prayers too fast you know who you are or
the preacher who goes on a bit too long
guess who it's not always been easy
our connection to god does not determine
our connection to the internet so
tonight
shall we pray to that mysterious
invisible power that's all around us
that ties us to everything in god's
creation
i'm not talking about the holy spirit i
mean the wi-fi
however you're joining us tonight and we
are glad that you're here
we're honored to have vice president joe
biden and president donald trump with us
i want to thank them both for keeping
alive the six
decade tradition that both candidates
would attend the l smith dinner
and for standing with us in solidarity
with the most vulnerable members of our
community
our children this year after all not not
only have
we had our nasal cavities tested our
faith has as well
so many lives lost to this deadly virus
in this country and around the world
more than 30 000 alone here in this
great city we love
new york city and in what seemed like
minutes
the heart of the country became the eye
of the storm
but we weathered it we persevered the
best we could
we stayed home we wore masks we checked
in on our neighbors we prayed we stood
on our balconies and cheered on the
front line workers
every night like vespers with applause
in so many ways the distance has brought
us closer
closer together to one another to our
families friends and to the lord
and for that i thank god
the virus has shown us how vulnerable we
are
yes but also how connected how connected
we are
that's why we're here tonight to help
make us whole
through good humor and good works we've
lost a lot
we've given up a lot but through it all
we've held on to our faith
and tonight we pay tribute to those who
have helped us through
they've strengthened our faith they've
earned our trust
and are deeply deserving of our
gratitude new york city's frontline
workers
in march of this year the unthinkable
happened
the city known the world over for its
unstoppable pace
came to a sudden halt
[Music]
the coronavirus reached our shores and
new york became the epicenter of the
worst global pandemic
in over a century
[Music]
the world watched as infection rates
escalated
the pain the suffering and the loss of
life that followed
was something we could not have imagined
governor cuomo declared a state of
emergency and all non-essential
businesses were asked to close
the city came to a stop
[Music]
[Applause]
except for those dedicated frontline
workers
who kept going to keep us safe
sacrificing their lives
and their family's well-being so that we
may live
[Music]
while the work is far from over the city
crossed a critical threshold this summer
when the infection rate for coronavirus
fell to less than one percent
key to new york survival were the
essential workers
these were the men and women who were
committed to keeping us
all safe and keeping the city running
while the pandemic swept through our
hospitals and cemeteries
our essential workers medical
professionals and first responders
work tirelessly for the people of our
city some
laying down their lives for their fellow
new yorkers
they taught us that if we beat the at
once
we can do it again but only together
[Music]
the alfred e smith memorial foundation
awarded eight million dollars in coveted
relief in march of 2020
as soon as the pandemic broke out 16
charities received funding
the foundation realized that it would
take all of us
working together making sure that
resources went to those who needed it
most
to all our essential workers and
emergency response personnel
our gratitude to you and your families
is unending
history will honor your sacrifice and
your heroism in the service of humanity
at this critical moment of crisis in our
city
and the world from all of us
at the alfred e smith memorial
foundation
thank you
[Music]
you know jesus promised wherever two or
three are gathered in my name
i'm there with them and tonight i'm
relieved to say that we've met that
minimum because
i'm joined here tonight by my good
friend mary callahan
erdos mary is the ceo
of jpmorgan asset wealth management
along with her husband phillip and their
three sacred heart daughters
all dedicate their time and so many
efforts to great works in the community
and i'm grateful to say including the
archdiocese of new york
and we're so fortunate to have her as
the chair of the alfred
smith memorial foundation now tonight
mary is going to speak of the legacy of
this dinner one that for three quarters
of a century
has brought together leaders regardless
of political affiliation
background whatever and provided common
ground might i even say
sacred ground and that's a tradition we
cherish
and it endures thanks to you mary and to
the entire al
smith board so it's my pleasure to
welcome you
mary callahan erdos thank you very much
for your leadership well thank you your
eminence it is so special to be here
in your home home to so many of the
archbishops of new york city
and it's such a historic place we're
just we're just thrilled it's really an
honor and a privilege as we just saw
from the video
new york city was one of the hardest hit
cities in our nation
by this terrible virus and throughout it
all
the cardinal the priests the deacons
the dedicated laity they kept working to
keep the church going
this home which is connected to st
patrick's cathedral
is such a special place not just for all
of us new yorkers
but really everyone that visits this
great city
but for the first time in a hundred and
forty year history
the doors were shut for weeks on end
normally the cathedral is a special
place of prayer and respite
for people of all faiths but you all
worked
tirelessly to find a way to bring a
sense of community
and prayer virtually into the homes
of all of those in need and even when
the unrest in the city this summer
resulted in degrading graffiti at the
very
entrance to this special place you
led by example and sought to build
bridges
one of my most cherished memories of the
time was when you asked rabbi joseph
potassnik
and reverend a.r bernard to join you in
reminding the people of new york city
how to come together
across not just religious but also
racial
lines and to use faith not violence
as the bomb to help ease our pain
together
the three of you reopened the houses of
worship across new york city
and of the country and for that and so
many other things
on behalf of all of us watching i just
want to thank you you're welcome for all
you do how gracious thank you
we've come a long way because of leaders
like his eminence
for understanding all religions and all
backgrounds a century ago though
this country had a very different tone
in 1928
alfred e smith was the first catholic
ever nominated
to run for president of the united
states at that time he was new york's
beloved governor
four terms in fact but in 1928 the rest
of the country had backlash
against his roman catholic faith it was
palpable
many warned that the election might mean
that the pope would run the white house
they had crazy fabricated stories that
the holland tunnel
was being built as a secret passageway
to bring the pope from rome fake news
way back when but enough fake news to
prevent him from winning
after al smith's death in 1944 francis
cardinal spellman started this tradition
of light-hearted political black-tie
dinners to honor al smith
and to raise money for children in need
but importantly
without regard for religion race
or other factors that sometimes divide
us
and even more special is that every four
years the presidential candidates are
invited to come speak at the dinner
just weeks before election day in the
heat of the campaign
they come and offer us a roast they're
usually
humble selves by the laughter in the
face of what's otherwise a super
stressful time
75 years of this tradition in my opinion
that's pretty special let's take a look
at some of the highlights from some of
those memorable moments
of those very special evenings the
annual dinner of the alfred e smith
memorial foundation
being held this evening in the grand
ballroom of the waldorf astoria hotel
here in new york city the eminence
cardinal spelman
this gathering enhanced for his purpose
and salutation
to the memory of al smith none in our
generation
more warmly sympathize with the needs
the hopes
the aspirations of humanity then did
governor smith
i'm glad to be here at this notable
dinner once again
and i'm glad that mr nixon is here also
and finally around 4 am this morning the
ghost of al
smith appeared at my bedside and he said
mr president i have seen the guest list
for that dinner too
i can't sleep either
and as we marvel at how far we've come
let us also remember how far
we've yet to go i must say i have
traveled a banquet circuit for many
years i've never quite understood the
logistics of dinners like this and how
the absence of one individual could
cause three of us to not have seats
[Applause]
and america's best days are truly
yet to come i know some people are going
to keep accusing me of exaggeration so
let me be clear those people seek
nothing less than the complete
destruction of the american way of life
i'm pleased to be here with the vice
president this evening
he's been promising to work harder on
getting some of the details right and i
hope he follows through
the other night after our third debate
just as i was leaving he said i look
forward to seeing you for the dinner in
new york i
meet you at the carlyle and dress as
casual
now al you are right a campaign can
require a lot of wardrobe changes
we uh blue jeans in the morning perhaps
a
suit for a lunch fundraiser sport coat
for dinner but it's nice to
finally relax and to wear what and i
wear around the house
in less than three weeks voters in
states like ohio
virginia and florida will decide this
incredibly important election which begs
the question
what are we doing here
[Music]
in the end what makes this dinner
important or not the jokes we tell but
the legacy that we carry forward
it is often easy to forget how far this
country has come
[Music]
one thing we can all agree on is the
need to support the great work
that comes out of the dinner millions of
dollars have been raised
to support disadvantaged children and i
applaud the many people
who have worked to make this wonderful
event
a critical lifeline for children
in need
with that is the history we were not
going to give up during these extra
unusual times and pass up the chance to
come together and roast
while tonight turned out to be so
different than what we had been planning
for the past several months
in many ways it's been even more
impactful because many more of you
can enjoy this from across the country i
have to tell you
that on behalf of the board of the
alfred e smith memorial foundation
we just cannot thank you enough our
donors
for not flinching you didn't ask for
your money back
you kept giving more as always
this event is a hundred percent
underwritten by the board of directors
every dollar raised goes to new york
city's neediest and boy
did you make your mark this year these
past several months
in one of the hardest hit coveted cities
around our nation
and the world your generosity allowed us
to grant over
eight million dollars to 16 different
charities
to feed educate and continue health
services
for the millions of people across new
york city
you helped the calvary hospital to add
hundreds of beds
you enabled catholic charities to give
out over a million meals
and you provided elizabeth seton
pediatric center
to add more front-line workers to hold
the hands
of the terminally ill children who
weren't allowed to be with their parents
all of you joining remotely ceos elected
officials
essential workers constituents
individual donors who bought tickets
or just those of you who accidentally
turned on c-span to help you fall asleep
all of you are in for a very special
treat
another shot at the tuesday night debate
but this time with the power of divine
intervention
the cardinal has been granted the power
to mute
the speakers when necessary
so with that we are going to begin with
vice president joseph biden
if elected vice president biden would
certainly make al smith proud
becoming our nation's second catholic
president
ladies and gentlemen please welcome vice
president
joseph biden thank you mary for that
introduction
your eminence cardinal dolan and
everyone
at the site of the al smith memorial
foundation thank you all for having me
and for supporting the charities that
care for new york's children and
families in need
in the name of a good man who believed
that faith without works is dead
for we know alfred e smith by what he
did
i know there's disappointment that the
dinner tonight couldn't continue as
normal
for us to sit together and put politics
aside for a night
because these are difficult times for
our country a pandemic
a recession a reckoning on race a
changing climate
with each crisis our faith is tested
faith in our institutions in one another
in truth in science and reason we have
to guard
ourselves from rationalizing that this
is normal and from numbing us to the
pain and suffering
of so many fellow americans you know
too many people woke up this morning
went to the kitchen table
and there was an empty chair were just
days ago or weeks ago or a month ago
a loved one sat talking laughing sharing
their dreams
and now they're gone lost to a
relentless and unforgiving virus
i know for me my catholic face has
helped me through the darkness
as i've had to bury pieces of my soul
deep in the earth
and eventually found purpose to live a
life
worthy of those i lost and throughout my
life in public service
i've been guided by the tenants of
catholic social doctrine
that cuts across all confessional faiths
what you do to the least among us you do
unto me
we have an obligation to one another we
cannot serve ourselves at the expense of
others
we have a responsibility to future
generations
and that's the charge before us today i
know it's hard to see
it right now our problems are so
systemic
the losses are so catastrophic at times
it feels easy to say
we're done it's over what's the point
but the american people don't give up
there is no
quit in america mark my words
one day we'll look back in awe not at
how far we fell but how fiercely we
fought back as a country
and that sense of hope and possibility
reminds me of the first time i met pope
francis
in 2013 when i had the privilege of
attending his inauguration at the
vatican
when i greeted him he said mr vice
president you're always welcome here
he was really sending a message to the
world to put out a welcome sign
on the front door of our church two
years later
president obama and i welcomed him at
the white house at that same
moment we shared a sense of hope and
possibility together and for me
it came at a very personal moment a very
tough time in the life of my family
our son beau had just died a few months
earlier
but pope francis took the time
to meet with my entire family to help us
see the light through the darkness
i live in an amazing country we all live
an amazing country
we're an irish catholic kid like me from
scranton pennsylvania would one day
befriend the jesuit pope
but that's who we are as a country where
anything is possible
when we care for one another when we
look out for one another
we keep the faith may god bless you all
i may god bless america and may god
protect our troops
thank you so much mr vice president
thank you for making the time
i know it's a very busy week and it's
very special to hear from you
and now we're going to turn to our next
speaker it feels like a lifetime ago
that the cardinal and i sat between
secretary clinton and president trump
four years ago as cardinal dolan said
it was the iciest place on the planet
this year president trump told us he
wants to toast
not roast let's hope for that the
president might not
publicly discuss his faith very often
but i have heard it said
that he alone has gotten more liberals
to pray to god
than any other president or cardinal in
recent history
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
president of the united states of
america
donald trump it is a profound honor to
address the 75th annual
al smith dinner for generations this
wonderful event has been a
revered institution in new york and new
york life
i fondly remember attending with my
father a long time ago i was a young man
but never forgot it
this organization's incredible tradition
of catholic charity
exemplifies the very best not only of
this city
but of this country i want to thank
cardinal dolan a very special man for
his extraordinary stewardship of the
archdiocese
and for his deep dedication to god and
to our nation
i also want to thank him for all of the
help he's given me
and so many things in so many different
ways thank you very much cardinal we
very much appreciate it
let me also thank mary erdos and the
entire
alfred e smith memorial foundation as
you know tonight's al smith dinner
is unlike any other sadly our country
and the entire world have been struck
with a
once-in-a-lifetime global pandemic china
shouldn't have let it happen
but it did when the virus came in from
china
we saw new yorkers respond with a same
grit and tenacity courage and
selflessness that have always defined
this city
that we love so much doctors and nurses
worked around the clock
the heroes of the new york pd nypd we
love them and they endorse me so i like
them even more but they are great
new york's finest and the fdny the
bravest
they are the bravest they're great i
know them all very well
and other first responders risked their
lives to save others
and of course the catholic community and
the men and women of the new york
archdiocese
answered the call and frankly answered
it
like nobody else could in catholic
schools hospital shelters soup kitchens
and food pantries
you served with the supreme devotion to
your fellow citizens
the alfred e smith memorial foundation
made a historic
8 million dollar gift to support the
children and the families
of new york thank you you showed the
world the essence of the catholic faith
i've known about it for a long time i
lived right next to a
magnificent catholic church as jesus
christ said in the gospel
everyone will know that you are my
disciples
if you love one another as president i
want to thank the catholic community for
the magnificent generosity you showed in
america's hour of need
we mourn for all of those who lost a
loved one
and in their memory we will defeat the
virus
through advances in treatment we have
reduced the fatality rate by 85
since just april we are on track to
develop and distribute a vaccine before
the end of the year and maybe
substantially before and i just want to
say that the end of the pandemic
is in sight and next year will be one of
the greatest years in the history of our
country
from the very beginning of our republic
catholics have uplifted
and enriched our nation beyond measure
catholics like
charles carroll helped secure american
independence
women like saint elizabeth ann seton
founded a movement that
created thousands of schools and lifted
children
out of poverty and the great al smith
the original happy warrior that's what
he was he was a happy warrior i know it
well
i consider myself to be a happy warrior
but it's not so easy in these times
but he was a happy warrior of american
politics he spent his life fighting for
hard-working americans
and battling the anti-catholic prejudice
that you see even today coming out of
the democrat party
today this amazing group continues that
proud tradition of faithful service
your work reminds us of an essential
truth
in this country civil society and
especially our religious
institutions are an essential foundation
of american freedom
our nation is strong because of
catholics and frankly
people of all faiths that is why as
president one of my top priorities is to
defend religious liberty
and the cherished role of faith and
faith-based organizations in our
national life to protect your god-given
rights i was recently honored to
nominate
one of our most brilliant legal minds
judge amy coney barrett
to the united states supreme court and
that was an honor indeed
she is a proud graduate of the
university of notre dame law school
where her professor one of the most
respected anywhere in the country said
she was the single
greatest student he has ever had in his
class we will not stand for any attacks
against judge barrett's faith
anti-catholic bigotry
has absolutely no place in the united
states of america
it predominates in the democrat party
and we must do something immediately
about it
like a republican win and let's make it
a really big one
to support the noble mission of catholic
schools
my administration is working to advance
school choice
it was my great honor to help the
catholic church with its schools
they needed hundreds of millions of
dollars nationwide
and i got it for him nobody else i got
it for him i hope you remember that on
november 3rd
but i got it for him and it was an honor
to do it i did it at the request of
cardinal dolan and others of your
leaders
they really needed it we took care of
that situation
very important we are once again
standing with catholic charities and
health care providers
such as the little sisters of the poor
we've been with them all the way in this
long fight
we are fighting for catholic adoption
agencies and fighting hard
and we are defending the sacred right
to life remember that when you vote
that's so important and so important to
the supreme court
every child born and unborn is made in
the holy image of god
few institutions in history have done
more for new york
more for america or more for people of
the world
than the catholic church from the
parishes of this city
came the soldiers who fought to end
slavery the workers who raised up the
towering skyline of manhattan
the chaplains who landed on the beaches
of guadalcanal
the nuns who marched for civil rights
and the police officers and firefighters
who we loved so much
who ran into the world trade center on
september 11
2001. now more than ever our nation
needs a renewal
of the values that this organization
promotes
and that the catholic faithful live out
each and every day
in peace we love the catholic
people we love the catholic religion
and above all we respect it greatly as
president i will always support you
in your effort to serve our fellow
citizens and to lift up
all humanity i will protect the catholic
church
and i will defend the rights of
religious believers of every race
religion color and creed thank you once
again to the al smith memorial
foundation
god bless you god bless new york and god
bless america
thank you mr president that was
extraordinarily
gracious mary am i mistaken or did we
just see
a rather peaceful transition a
transition to the
the microphones and it wasn't so bad was
it mr president
uh i'm grateful to president trump and
vice president biden for joining us this
evening
i'd also dare remind them that al smith
was a happy lawyer but he was never a
sore loser
uh we're also grateful to all of our
donors you realize we've raised over
five million dollars that'll go to
support new york city's children
jesus said whatever you do to the least
among us you did it to me
well you've done a lot this evening and
we thank you
this dinner has spanned three quarters
of a century
our democracy nearly 250 years
and our church a lot longer than that
these institutions have persevered
through war and famine pandemic and
strife
because of people like you people who
are willing to set aside their
differences to achieve a common goal a
higher goal
even dare we say the ultimate goal of
salvation
i'm reminded tonight if you don't mind
me sharing of two such people
one was my beloved predecessors john
cardinal o'connor
who served this archdiocese in new york
from 1984 to the year 2000
many of you will remember him fondly as
a man of deep faith
and strong convictions always willing to
fiercely defend the church and her
teachings
now you also might remember that the
mayor of that time
at that time was the colorful ed koch
proud of his jewish heritage a man of
equally strong convictions always ready
to defend his beliefs no matter the cost
it would be fair to say i think that
cardinal o'connor and ed koch
would find themselves on opposite ends
of the political spectrum
and on many occasions doing battle on
the delicate issues of the day even
going to court to settle some of their
disputes but you know what
they were also the best of friends it
was to cardinal o'connor that mayor koch
turned during a
particularly difficult time in his
leadership
and as he was battling depression the
cardinal
relished his meals and visits with the
mayor even
long after ed koch had left office the
two of them even wrote a book together
and on the night that koch lost to bid
for reelection
most people flocked to congratulate the
victor
the cardinal said i want to go see my
friend ed koch just to be with him on
this difficult night
theirs was a friendship based on dignity
a sense of joy and mutual respect
on recognizing that there's more that
unites us than divides us
in these past months we've seen lives
lost jobs lost
homes destroyed families disheartened
we've sacrificed so much and will
continue to sacrifice so much
for as long as this pandemic lasts
however
let our hearts not be hardened let them
be open
let us leave here changed and resolved
to go forth
with respect and dignity for all that's
the nature of this
el smith dinner shall we end as we began
in prayer
in the name of the father and of the son
and of the holy spirit let us pray
god bless america land that we love
god bless our two candidates keeping
them safe and vigorous these important
weeks of democracy in action
god mend thine every flaw the sickness
the tensions the continued challenges to
justice peace
unity protection of life and
international reconciliation
god bless the al smith foundation its
board and benefactors and most of all
the people in need especially women and
children
we're so honored to serve we seek the
gift of everlasting life for our past
benefactors
and leaders especially al smith iv whom
we miss so very much
mary higgins clark dennis kelleher
vincent rowan carol sayer all of whom
passed away this year
as well as vice president biden's son
beau and president trump's brother
robert
we make our prayer through christ our
lord amen in the name of the father the
son the holy spirit
well good night and god bless see you in
person i hope next year
[Laughter]
[Music]
mary
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
b
what purpose does the gentleman from
michigan seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr butterfield of north carolina
pursuant to hres 965
i informed the house
foreign
you